well brian nevada business advisors say
one of the reasons are just some of the
reasons actually why many businesses
weren't able to secure
funding through the paycheck protection
program was either
lack of proper documentation and just
simply misinformation
but there is more help on the way eight
news now reporter sally jaramillo spoke
to a latino owned business
who is now considering applying again
when we were playing for the loan was
because well mostly because you know
businesses were hurting rodrigo ivara is
a director of operations for don tortaco
mexican grill
last year he says they applied for the
paycheck protection program
all in effort to keep employees employed
our options were
you know to save money we'd have to cut
hours you know
lay people off and you know pretty much
do things that we don't want to do which
was you know people were already hurting
something west flamingo lindo michoacan
general manager
nimva magana relates with like everybody
else
we felt so heartbroken because it
our main concern was for all employees
what was going to happen to everybody
in this particular location 70 families
depend on our under
income from this particular location
despite the situation being stressful
and having to wait without knowing if
they would get the help
ivara and magana are glad they applied
having that little relief to help
again the employees and to keep
everything going again
it's life-saving ivara says as they look
forward to this new year
we're looking to do bigger expansions
and stuff to our bit like how we
how we uh how we do our like sales
so like we're gonna need more people to
have it
you know function smoothly their message
to other business owners tonight well i
recommend
constantly applying and kind of like you
know not giving up but this time we're
more confident because the process is
going to be very similar to the first
sally jaramillo 8 news now
so for more information on how you can
apply or maybe you've never reached out
to nevada business advisors we do have
information for you on our website at
8newsnow.com